in an interview conducted in front of
the Lincoln Memorial President Trump
claims he's the most persecuted
president in history including Honest
Abe
while everyone on the left and the right
mock the wild claimed fewer picking up
on the Keene piece of political wisdom
and Trump's statement then Michigan
dictate ryx Gretchen Whitmer calls her
conservative constituents Nazis the New
York Times wins a pew litter for
rewriting American history and the
federal government predicts more deaths
from coronavirus all that more I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Nolt show
[Music]
so which is it who is more persecuted
President Trump or Abraham Lincoln I
know a lot of factors to weigh here
you know half the country seceding from
the Union and getting shot in a theater
and also having to deal with Jim Acosta
those are two key signs of persecution
at the very least more than two so
please let us know in the comments
section below
people are making fun of him for this it
actually shows us a key political truth
something that lies at the heart of a
lot of the conservative debates today at
the heart of politics we'll get to that
in a second first I got to thank our
friends over at eight your life you know
I want to thank all of our sponsors for
six sticking with us in this very
difficult time right now and I want you
to patronize our sponsors because not
only are they sticking with us in
keeping the show on the air but they
have an unbelievable product
particularly paint your life you know
I've taken up painting during this
quarantine and I've had mixed results
let's put it charitably I've not you
know I can promise you I am NOT one of
the on staff painters that paint your
life they have much better painters than
than I it's very important to have
artwork in the house it took me years
and years to realize this now I love it
if you're looking for a way to feel
connected to loved ones when you can't
be near try paint your life calm you get
a professional hand painted portrait
created from any photo at a truly
affordable price you can choose from a
team of world-class artists work with
them until every detail is perfect it's
so easy you send a picture of yourself
your kids your family a special place of
a photo or a pet rather or you can
combine photos and they will paint an
actual if you want an oil portrait or
other kinds as well I got an oil
portrait it's just an unbelievable
anniversary gift Mother's Day gift I
can't speak highly enough of these guys
it's such an amazing product at paint
your life calm there is no risk if you
don't love the final painting your money
is refunded guaranteed right now for a
limited offer you get 20% off your
painting that is 20% off and free
shipping to get this offer text Michael
to 64,000 Michael to 64,000 that's mi CH
AE L to 64,000 paint your life celebrate
the moments that matter most
so in this interview conducted before
the Lincoln Memorial giant Abraham
Lincoln looking down on President Trump
he's there speaking with Martha McCallum
and Bret Baier they're taking some
questions from people around the country
and one woman who says she's a trump
supporter asks Trump a question about
his style and the style point here is
why is Trump so mean why does he get
into these fights why does he brawl with
people who are critics of his and who
are the mainstream media but I repeat
myself and Trump's answer is very
indicative of a major divide on the
right here's the question why do you use
descriptive words that could be
classified as bullying and why do not
directly answer the questions asked by
the press but instead speak of past
successes and generally ramble the US I
need you please let go of those
behaviors that are turning people away
from you please hold on to your
wonderful attributes that make you our
great leader and let go of other
characteristics that do not serve you
good I think I like that question I'm
not sure but I think I like that
question I appreciate it I appreciate
the prayers too very much now look at
this response to this his response is
disproving a little bit of the point
that this woman is trying to make is a
woman saying why are you so mean why are
you such a jerk
surely Trump is a jerk sometimes but
he's not a jerk all the time and his
response in at least initially is
actually to charm her right it's not to
yell at her and say how dare you I'm a
nice guy I'm a cool guy he goes I think
I like that question I think she's
complimenting me I'm not so sure but
okay we'll get into it thank you for the
question thank you for the prayers so
we're seeing their different sides to
the guys personality but no one can deny
he does get into fights he is mean he
does boast about his accomplishments he
does correct reporters and and get testy
with reporters he does that as he says
because he has to
I am greeted with a hostile press the
likes of which no president has ever
seen the closest would be that gentleman
right up there they always said Lincoln
nobody got treated worse than Lincoln I
believe I am treated worse
you there you see those press
conferences they come at me with
questions that are disgraceful to be
honest disgraceful the Amanar of
presentation and their words and I feel
that if I was kind to them I'd be I'd be
walked off the stage
I mean if they come at you with the most
horrible horrendous biased questions and
you see it 94 a 95 percent of the press
is hostile and yet if you look in
Florida today we had hundreds and
hundreds of boats going up and down the
intercoastal Trump Trump we have
tremendous support but the media is they
might as well be in the Democrat Party
you knew the president from could not do
an interview sitting in front of this
giant Abraham Lincoln without comparing
himself to Lincoln and so that's the
line that everybody's talking about and
that's what the reason that the whole
clip is going viral and it's very good
that that clip is going viral because it
shows a key defense of the Trump air and
it gives us a little bit of advice
moving forward Trump does not have the
advantage of being nice that's what he's
saying saying look do I want to be nice
yeah maybe I do want to be nice but he
doesn't have the advantage of being nice
Republicans and conservatives who
actually want to accomplish something in
politics do not have the advantage of
being nice that's if you want to
accomplish something that's if you want
to win some Republicans and
conservatives don't want to win I'm not
saying this as some kind of personal
attack on them I am NOT I don't think
I'm being hyperbolic here I think it's
pretty clear that some Republicans and
conservatives feel much more comfortable
losing gracefully than winning when you
win there's a risk to that then you have
to do something
then you're gonna be held accountable
for what you've done you might make a
mistake you might do the wrong thing if
you lose gracefully then you get to
preserve your purity then people can
like you then the New York Times will
write nice things about you once you've
lost I mean I think of of people like
John McCain for instance in politics
John McCain didn't want to win in 2008
he didn't
play to win he played to lose he
suspended his presidential campaign
thank God like you could you couldn't
possibly show more clearly how you're
not trying to win John McCain wanted the
New York Times to like him John McCain
campaigned on repealing Obamacare for
years and years and years and years and
years and then he had the opportunity to
do it and he didn't do it he didn't want
to do it he he and he's just one example
among many there but Mitt Romney's there
are other Republicans too who would much
rather play by the rules of liberalism I
call this kind of conservatism court
jester conservatism they would rather be
the court jester in the kingdom of
liberalism than actually strike out on
their own and change the political
realities around us you know they would
rather be different versions of this
kind of kind of conservative they would
rather be Archie Bunker or Ron Swanson
this kind of neat little liberal
caricature of a conservative fit into a
nice little box within the broader
framework of liberalism you know
somewhat likeable maybe but ultimately a
joke we see this now with the Justin
Amash campaign for president there's
Justin Amash is that libertarian
congressman who's running for president
now against Donald Trump of course he'll
never win as of now his political career
is completely dead he is just a sort of
media phenomenon and a musing phenomenon
is stretching that word to a ridiculous
extent but he's playing a role within
the liberal framework right he's playing
by the left's premises and filling a
role left for conservatives by the left
so you know Ron Swanson right the Parks
and Rec character he's this kind of
curmudgeonly conservative and he can't
really accomplish anything but you know
he can be sort of frustrated and
curmudgeonly same thing with any
conservative character that has ever
been on television which is they make
him kind of curmudgeonly and but
ultimately you like him but you like him
mostly because he's ineffectual
there are a lot of conservatives who
want to play that role who want to be
the curmudgeonly but ineffectual right
winger who you know he resists the waves
of progress with a capital P but you
know ultimately he
really succeed those are the
conservatives who want to lose some
conservatives want to win okay when you
want to win you've got to be everything
when you want to win you've got to be
the visionary the speaker the organizer
the policy wonk the newsman the
entertainer the critic and the historian
and it's funny because when you're the
Entertainer in a way you've got to be
kind of a court jester are you at least
got to engage people on this this level
of entertainment but you're playing by a
different set of rules here you've got
to be everything though Donald Trump in
the same answer has to be mean and
serious and tough to Jim Acosta but
really nice and charming to his
supporter and he's also got to be the
historian because the left always
rewrites history so he's got to remind
everybody of his own accomplishments and
we'll see how the left rewrites history
in just a moment with the New York Times
he's also got to be the news man because
the news can't be expected to report
what he's doing honestly and so he's got
to correct the record on the news he's
got to put out his own counter news
narrative you've got to do all of these
things if you want to accomplish
anything because the entire edifice of
politics is premise on liberalism it is
working against you it is progressive
they're probably the greatest example of
this in the last hundred years
his Winston Churchill right Winston
Churchill Trump compares himself to
Abraham Lincoln I now I'll try to make a
comparison to Winston Churchill
Churchill did this the best better than
anybody he was the visionary he was the
speaker he was also the historian he
wrote the history of the
english-speaking people the history of
the Second World War he was also the
entertainer he's probably known more for
his one-liners
for his wit than he is for his military
strategy he was also a newsman he was
actually a journalist himself during
Wars he was an organizer he was a policy
wonk he was all of it you have to be all
of it the Liberals the left don't have
to be all of that because they've got
the mainstream media back-to-back mom
Joe Biden said just yesterday or the day
before that the Biden campaign is
relying on the media to deal with this
terror read investigation because he's
not going to be able to do that it's too
difficult they've got the media they've
got the bureaucracy they've got the
university
they've got Hollywood they've got the
historians I guess are at the University
and they're at Hollywood sometimes
Hollywood rewrites history too they've
got all of it okay so their job is much
much easier and for conservatives who
don't care about winning for
conservatives who just want to go along
to get along and play a role but not
change anything in politics they don't
need to worry that much either they've
just got to fill their own little silo
but if you want to change things in
politics you've got to do a lot more and
sometimes that means being mean to Jim
Acosta and that's just too bad we talked
yesterday on the show about how this is
not neutral playing ground okay there's
no kumbaya and no getting along the left
is now going to kumbaya with you we'll
get to how that is in a second first I
got to thank our friends over at legacy
box you know Mother's Day is coming up
shopping for mothers is very difficult
but it doesn't have to be you can just
give her photos and videos of you isn't
that really nice she actually I'm sure
she will love that all mothers love that
kind of stuff
legacy box is a super simple mail and
service to have all your home movies and
pictures digitally preserved on a thumb
drive DVD or the cloud don't let those
priceless family memories disappear
because that's what happens if you don't
take action and instead what you can do
is put all those memories get them out
of the dusty boxes put them up make them
digital legacy box helps bring new life
to your old media but it'll put them in
a modern digital format that is easy to
use so go check it out right now I
actually had a family member who very
sadly died and I was very afraid that I
was gonna lose every photo that I had of
her and you know I couldn't miss I would
misplace the physical photos I put them
up on legacy box now they're there
forever for a limited time legacy box is
running 50% off Mother's Day special or
your legacy box today to take advantage
of this incredible offer this is one of
the best discounts they've ever offered
legacy box is perfect for you or for
someone you love legacy box comm slash
Knowles save 50% while supplies last
you know sometimes conservatives like
during the Tea Party era for instance
they love to waive that Gadsden flag
that's the yellow flag with the snake on
it it says don't tread on me
I like that flag it's an early
revolutionary flag but that that flag
kind of plays into the that liberal
premise a little bit I think in modern
times you know that don't tread on me
just leave me alone I'm not really gonna
engage in trying to change politics I
just want to be left alone and so it's
not my favorite flag you know I've still
got it I've got it on my desk sand
things like that but the flag that I
prefer is one of the original American
flags it's called the Bedford flag and
it really shows you political stakes
it's a knight's arm coat of arms and
it's holding a sword and it says Vinci
out Maria Rey conquer or die that's
politics for you all right though to
quote cocaine Mitch McConnell the
winners go and mate make laws and the
losers go home there's no if you lose
gracefully you'll get a nice write-up in
the New York Times maybe and you will
have no effect whatsoever progressivism
as we talked about yesterday is out to
destroy everything you cherish you are
the target okay no kumbaya no play play
nice on the left listen to the way the
Gretchen Whitmer of Michigan talks about
her conservative constituents some
conservative constituents came out the
other day they were protesting these
draconian and arbitrary lockdown orders
regular good old American patriots
waving the American flag whitmer I guess
she was looking at a different scene at
the Capitol than we all were all she
could see were Nazis in the Ku Klux Klan
displayed like the one that we saw our
capital is not representative of who we
are again there were swastikas and
Confederate flags and nooses and people
with assault rifles and that's the very
you know there's a small group of people
when you think about the fact that this
is a state of almost 10 million people
the vast majority of whom are doing the
right thing and that's why we've seen
our curve get pushed down we've saved
lives in the process and we have to keep
listening to the epidemiologists and
experts and not listen to the partisan
rhetoric or these political rallies or
or tweets
that matter we have to keep doing the
right thing the next right thing all of
my opponents are Nazis they're all
Klansmen they're racists they're
terrible evil bigoted people and we've
got to tone down the partisan rhetoric
okay
we shouldn't listen to politicians we
should only listen to epidemiologists hi
I'm governor Gretchen Whitmer PhD MD is
she I don't know I don't think so I
don't think she's a doctor or an
epidemiologist no I mean it's
cartoonishly absurd language that she's
using none of which is true none of
which is true first of all we don't need
to only listen to the epidemiologists
we're a free people who govern ourselves
of course we need to engage in politics
we don't just export all of our politics
and outsource them to the exalted doctor
foul Qi I don't remember reading that in
the Constitution we govern ourselves and
it's only the demagogues right now who
were saying get politics out of this
kind of ironic it's only the political
demagogues we're telling people to get
politics out of this but then what about
her claims she says that there were all
these Nazis and Ku Klux Klan at the
rally I mean I didn't go to the protest
in Michigan but I saw a lot of videos
from it I got to tell you I didn't see
any swastikas I didn't see any Ku Klux
Klan hoods we've got some video of it
let me tell you what if you've if you've
seen any going around on the internet if
you can listen to the chants here do you
hear any any people shouting in German
[Music]
big round of applause for wine I'm
looking around that scene I got to tell
you I don't see any Nazi flags I see a
lot of American flags I see that well
actually the one Nazi symbol that I see
is somebody depicting Gretchen Whitmer
as Hitler maybe that's what she's on she
got confused is but if you if you've got
a sign portraying your political
opponent as Hitler or Mussolini or
whatever evil guy you want to talk about
then you're not a pro-nazi protestor
you're an anti-nazi protester I other
than that otherwise I see some Gadsden
Flags the flag we were just talking
about don't tread on me I see a lot of
American patriots who just don't want to
have their rights trampled by an
arbitrary government and yet she calls
all these people Nazis and racists
imagine if you had a right-wing rally we
were rather you had a right-wing
governor and a left-wing rally outside
and the governor was asked what do you
think about the protests you know and at
the let's say it was a left-wing protest
so it had lots of left-wing symbols it
had you know the gay pride flag and it
had I don't know some like some
environmentalist flag and it's just kind
of typical symbols you know the right
has the American flags and then the left
has all these kind of special interest
bikes and let's say that the Republican
governor came out and said oh all those
people yeah they're a bunch of
disgusting despicable deplorable
irredeemable irredeemable evil awful
people who have no place in this country
what would the reaction to that be no I
wouldn't support I'm a right-wing or I
wouldn't support that kind of rhetoric I
the media obviously wouldn't tolerate
that kind of rhetoric but that's the
place we're in the conservatives
generally try to play nice and the left
is playing for keeps
they're doing this not just by rewriting
the present okay they're not just
propagandizing in the present
progressives are also rewriting the past
not just the details not just some
characters in the past that they're
gonna tweak a little bit
they are rewriting now the fundamental
purpose of the American Revolution and
they're winning pule at surprises for it
we'll get to that one second first I've
got to thank our friends over at
NetSuite you know with this level of
economic uncertainty businesses need
systems that will give them complete
visibility into their numbers there is
enough uncertainty going around right
now
NetSuite reduces it by giving you
visibility and control with so many
critical decisions to make you need the
right numbers and you need them right
now
NetSuite by Oracle the world's number
one cloud business system with NetSuite
we give you financials cash flow payroll
inventory and more all in one place so
you have clear visibility and total
control of your business this is
necessary anytime but particularly in
these economic conditions you need to be
able to see your numbers otherwise of
missing a few numbers I can leave you
too late NetSuite customers have the
flexibility to work from anywhere with
immediate clarity on critical
information right at their fingertips
right now you can receive your free
guide managing business uncertainty and
schedule your free product or RightNow
and NetSuite comm / Knowles kano wles
don't wait to get your free guide and
schedule your free product tour at
NetSuite dot-com / Knowles canna wles
NetSuite comm / Knowles New York Times
just won a Pulitzer Prize and the
Pulitzer Prize came for its reporting on
the 16:19 project 1619 project traces
American history back to the arrival of
the first African slave in the American
colonies now even the history of how
slavery developed in the American
colonies is a complex one it's not
actually purely a racial thing as the
New York Times would have you believed
but that's not it look what we're not
even getting into the details here we're
just talking about the fundamental
premise the piece that won them the
Pulitzers by nicole Hannah Jones
called our democracy's founding ideals
were false when they were written black
Americans have fought to make them true
and ironically or perhaps not the piece
that they won their pew lats are for is
fundamentally incorrect so it begins my
dad always flew an American flag in our
front yard skip a little bit when I was
young that flag outside our home never
made sense to me how could this black
man having seen firsthand the way his
country abused black Americans how it
refused to treat them as full citizens
proudly fly its banner I didn't
understand his patriotism it deeply
embarrassed me so at least she's
admitting off the top that she hates her
country right oh yeah got to get points
for honesty here we get to the false
claim conveniently left out of our
founding mythology is the fact that one
of the primary reasons the colonists
decided to declare their independence
from Britain was because they wanted to
protect the institution of slavery that
is not true
there are many academic historians who
wrote into the New York Times to say
that that was not true in the New York
Times ignored them there is no evidence
for that whatsoever there's a lot of
evidence to the contrary for instance in
the Declaration of Independence one of
the chief complaints against the British
one of the reasons for which they were
declaring independence is because they
blamed the British for foisting slavery
on them slavery which they detest it and
then of course later on when they write
the Constitution the issue of slavery is
a big controversy because there were
many people who were drafting the
Constitution who wanted to abolish
slavery altogether there were many
people who did not want slavery to give
a reward to the south as a matter of
representation in Congress and so they
had to arrive at a compromise and they
had to sunset the importation of slaves
which they did in the Constitution and
then ultimately the inevitable Civil War
came to end slavery nothing about this
is true this was then roundly oh there's
also another false claim in here which
is pretty funny the woman who wrote it
doesn't even know when the Declaration
of Independence was
so initially she wrote that it was
signed on July 4th but actually the
signing began a couple weeks later on
August 2nd so more than a couple weeks
later on August 2nd so already you've
got the Pulitzer Prize winning essay
that has multiple Corrections right at a
correction and editors note and yet the
Pulitzer committee still gave it to them
including supporters of the 1619 project
you had lots of academic historians say
that this was trashed Northwestern
University professor Leslie Harris
writes of this on August 19th of last
year I listened in stunned silence as
Nicole Hannah Jones a reporter for The
New York Times repeated an idea that I
had vigorously argued against with her
fact checker that the Patriots fought
the American Revolution in large part to
preserve slavery in America
I've igger ously disputed the claim
although slavery was certainly an issue
in the American Revolution
the protection of slavery was not one of
the main reasons the 13 colonies went to
war so this historian and many other
historians spoke to the times about this
said guys we support the project we
support making slavery big focus when
you're writing the history of America
but just as a matter of history this is
not factually correct and they ignored
him which is a pattern for the New York
Times shown in 2018 the New York Times
shared a Pew LAT surprise for its
reporting on Russia Gate which as you
might recall is a complete hoax and a
complete hoax perpetrated by the left
and the media but I repeat myself and
which is one of the reasons the
president from can't be so nice with
everybody all the time is because you've
got the entire apparatus of modern
liberalism trying to completely destroy
this man now they're trying to destroy
American history as well and it's not
just happening in the pages of the New
York Times if it were wouldn't matter
because very few people read the New
York Times but the 16:19 project is now
being taught in schools this anti
historical trash is being taught in
schools as though it were history over
the dispute ations
of academic historians
who support the New York Times who
support the project but even they are
honest enough doesn't matter this will
be taught in schools and as we were
discussing yesterday on the show it with
regard to Phyllis Schlafly and the
rewriting of history on the Equal Rights
Amendment this is the kind of stuff
that's going to be remembered the
narrative is going to be remembered and
the real history increasingly is going
to be forgotten that's why they're
rewriting it in the first place this is
happening all around us it's not just
these kind of broad questions of who was
more persecuted Trump or Lincoln you
know kind of ridiculous questions it's
not just rewriting the American
Revolution it's happening in real time
on coronavirus president Trump finds
himself in a very difficult political
position right now and we've at least
got to shine a little bit of light on
the hypocrisy we'll get to that in one
second first though I've got to thank
our friends over at you time is running
out when you become a daily wire insider
plus or all access member what do you
get you know you get all the shows and
everything and you get the leftist ears
tumblr right oh yes and you get another
leftist here's tumblr you will get two
incredible magnificent leftist ears
tumblers but the deal ends today
all right nothing gold can stay this
will end today deals like this don't
come around very often so you want to
take advantage of it right now for
existing members I know you're feeling a
little envy don't worry we've got an
offer coming up for you in just a moment
so hold on tight but it get those two
left is too stumblers right now hurry
and become an insider plus or all-access
member to double your tears with two
leftist tears tumblers go to daily wire
comm / subscribe to get started and get
10% off with coupon code Knowles that is
10% off with coupon code Knowles get
yours before it's too late we'll be
right back
so we're not just rewriting the Trump
presidential politics we're not just
rewriting American history
we're also rewriting this pandemic in
real time so some bad news came from
President Trump just a couple days ago
which is a revision up of the projected
mortality you remember initially was two
million there was half a million there
was two hundred thousand was a hundred
thousand then dr. Fatih and president
drum said it would be about 60,000
possibly lower now president Trump is
revising those numbers up a little bit
again we did the right thing I do look
back on it because my attitude was we're
not going to shut it down look we're
gonna lose anywhere from seventy five
eighty to a hundred thousand people it's
a horrible thing we shouldn't lose one
person over this okay
eighty hold on 80,000 that's higher than
60,000 now the media going berserk at
president Trump how dare you the numbers
are going up it was only supposed to be
60 you have mishandled this it's all
falling apart sir president Trump is
getting hammered because he took the
estimate from 60 which is based on the I
hav model goes from 60 up to 80 say you
know numbers foul she gave us he's
getting hammered for that but the left
doesn't get hammered for bringing the
numbers down from 2.2 million to 80,000
or whatever it is now president Trump
fell into bad political positioning here
because it always looks bad to revise
the numbers up and it always looks good
to revise the numbers down and the media
had every incentive the left the
Democratic governors had every incentive
to scare the bejesus out of people and
get everything locked down right it
makes them look good it makes them look
like they're decisive leaders they then
discouraged employment through that
stimulus bill that was a key Democratic
provision to keep the economy down and
why do they want the economy down
because it's an election year and
obviously that will help their side and
her president Trump they've even
admitted this you know left-wing media
figure Bill Maher came out and said he'd
rather have a recession they get Trump
really
that's why we need to have a recession
right so they haven't exactly been
subtle about this that is what they're
cheering for and that's what we're
getting so Trump was already in that bad
position and in president Trump's
defense they keep moving the goal posts
on what this virus is on what qualifies
as a death on how it compares to other
plagues but they don't get any attacks
for getting the numbers so wrong in the
first place the intercept this was on
March 17th 2.2 million people in the US
could die if coronavirus goes unchecked
doesn't matter they could have said 2.2
billion people in the US you know many
many many times the u.s. population
wouldn't have mattered it wouldn't they
wouldn't get called out for it New York
Times you know those guys those experts
in American history Nicholas Kristof
column the best case outcome for the
coronavirus and the worse will we endure
2.2 million deaths or will we managed to
turn things around here's what he says
dr. Neal M Ferguson a British
epidemiologist who is regarded as one of
the best disease modelers in the world
produced a sophisticated model with the
worst case of 2.2 million deaths in the
United States
I asked Ferguson for his best case about
1.1 million deaths he said when that's a
best-case scenario it's difficult to
feel optimistic 1.1 million doesn't
matter though so you have these
hysterical alarmist numbers 1.1 million
at best 2.2 million at worst shuts down
the entire economy will certainly lead
to many deaths ruined many lives I think
it's upwards of 40 percent of small
businesses might go out of business
within six months no consequences for
that the president Trump touts a number
from doctor foul Chi 60,000 it gets
revised up by 20,000 he gets dragged for
it and the goal posts continue to move
another place we've seen this is with
flu deaths right and early on when we
were looking at this virus people said
okay well how does this compare to other
diseases other viruses makes perfect
sense one of the comparisons was to the
flu and we said okay well you know
upwards of 50 60 70 thousand people can
die from a bad flu year so if the
projections were getting four deaths
from coronavirus if
fifty sixty thousand seventy thousand
then yeah it seems about right I guess
we could make that comparison right and
then the left told us no you can't
compare it to the flu because that would
counter the hysterical alarmist
narrative so this is going on for about
five six weeks now and and the left has
had it with the flu comparison so now
they're touting a doctor geremy Samuel
Faust emergency medical physician an
instructor at Harvard Medical School who
published a blog post on Scientific
American saying that actually the
numbers we have for the flu deaths are
not really the numbers for the flu
deaths so the preliminary estimate for
flu deaths in the 2017-2018 season is
around sixty one thousand so certainly
within the ballpark of coronavirus but
the total number of confirmed flu deaths
is actually much lower he says he says
it's fifteen thousand six hundred and
twenty I don't know I'm not an expert on
these things none of us is we've been
relying on the numbers that the
scientific community has been giving us
which is sixty seventy thousand now all
of a sudden were being told no actually
sixty thousand is fifteen thousand so
the number you've got to compare
coronavirus to is fifteen thousand
that's why coronavirus is so much worse
which is it I can't keep up if we're
told we have to listen to the experts
then the experts have to give us your
reliable information so if the experts
are gonna keep moving the goal posts
then we can't rely on them at all then
it seems more and more to many Americans
who are clamoring to reopen like this is
a rigged game there is no political cost
I mean even on this case the flu deaths
no cost to lowering the estimates and
yet there is a great political cost to
increasing the estimates the new numbers
here do not tell us anything right the
new numbers on not just the flu but
uncor onna virus ticking it up from
sixty to eighty thousand doesn't tell us
anything doesn't change our behavior at
all I wish that it could change our
behavior but it doesn't it's just a
one-way political attack on Trump and it
can never be used in the other direction
why does it not change our behavior well
because the only policy that they've
come up with is the lockdowns right
social distancing where the masks
everywhere shut down the businesses the
only two
things that the lockdowns can possibly
accomplish or flatten the curve and
prevent the hospital system from being
overwhelmed and flatten the curve and
bias time until we get a vaccine
it doesn't mean stop the virus it means
flatten that curve and spread it out
we know that the hospital systems have
not been overwhelmed certainly not here
in California not even in New York
Javits Center Hospital was completely
empty that hospital ship the USNS
comfort very empty we know that we're
not going to get a virus anytime soon as
this disease this virus or we're not
gonna get a vaccine rather any time soon
as this virus spreads throughout the
population so what does the extra 20,000
deaths tell us doesn't tell us anything
about our own behavior just kind of some
sad news and politically it's a way to
attack Trump the key element to this
pandemic is hypocrisy okay no mistake by
the left is too great no mistake by the
right is too small
any missed and any miscalculation by the
right is evidence that the right got it
totally wrong any miscalculation by the
left
whoopsie-daisy never mind throw it down
the memory hole what do you mean 2.2
million deaths no that doesn't doesn't
ring a bell to me you see this most
clearly with Andy Cuomo Indy Cuomo
governor of New York being hailed as the
great leader in the coronavirus what a
strong articulate wonderful prepared
leader so much better than Trump
Democrats should nominate Cuomo in 2020
he could go head to head with Trump
Cuomo has failed he's done a terrible
job only in the Democratic Party could
you be the head of the worst prepared
State the hardest hit state for this
pandemic and have that taken as an
example of some great success here's
just here's just one little policy to
show it to you on Thursday
Andy Cuomo announced that they're gonna
start cleaning the subways
you know the subways in New York are
absolutely filthy they run all the time
and so now they're gonna for you know a
couple hours a night they're going to
start deep cleaning the subways and this
is important because they've reduced the
number of trains so already you're
cramming more people onto the subway
already the subways are moving homeless
shelters and have been for many years so
now they're gonna start cleaning them
two months into this pandemic now
they're gonna start cleaning the subways
why didn't you do that two months ago
you you great leader you brilliant
visionary who's so prepared Cuomo says
any essential worker who shows up and
gets on a train should know that that
train was disinfected the night before
because a lot of transit workers are
getting sick and they don't wanna come
into work it's realistic it's an
essential how realistic is it what's the
alternative yeah it is essential it is
realistic why didn't you do it two
months ago doesn't matter doesn't matter
Cuomo is not gonna get called out on it
another aspect of the hypocrisy on this
whole pandemic and this is this is
probably my favorite one is the my body
my choice argument you know the left has
told us for 5060 years now my body my
choice you have no right to tell me what
to do with my body this is the argument
they use to defend abortion now some
conservatives are saying with regard to
our imprisonment in our apartments and
the lockdown and the arbitrary exercise
of power we say wait a second what about
my body my choice I'm gonna go to the
beach because it's my body my choice and
the left responds and says that's not
just your body because when you go out
during a pandemic you're endangering
everybody else's body but of course that
plays to the very same point that the
Conservatives are making when it comes
to abortion where we say right it's not
just your body either it's the body
inside of you that you're killing the
left refuses to recognize this hypocrisy
and by the way it's not hypocritical for
the right to use first of all we're
using this argument a little
tongue-in-cheek
against the left to prove a point but
they're actually separate questions of
imperiling other people's lives because
when you go out during a pandemic you
are calculating certain amounts of risk
right so you're not just walking up to
people in coughing right in their face
and like licking their cheek or you know
you're going out you're being cautious
you're staying mostly away from people
you're washing your hands and there is
some risk obviously that diseases could
spread as there is always a risk that
diseases could spread as happens every
single day even in normal times but
there's a risk of natural death when you
are
sanctioning abortion you are not
calculating a risk of someone dying of a
natural death
you are permitting murder you're
permitting the targeted killing of an
innocent person
those are categorically different things
all of those distinctions are lost on
the left even the broader hypocrisy is
as well the reason for this is that the
left is not playing by some nice set of
rules that this is not a fair game okay
this is not a neutral playing ground
where we're all just kind of having a
debate and we'll see which ideas win and
you know we've just the right needs to
play by the Marquess of Queensbury rules
and everything we'll get along fine
no a key political truth that we are
being reminded of and an unfortunate
political truth perhaps but a truth
nonetheless is that politics in practice
is not primarily about principles it's
about winning and that is what the left
is in to do Joe Biden in a rare moment
of lucidity admitted this just the other
day when he's talking about the corona
virus and the response to the corona
virus he said the quiet part out loud he
said that this is a wonderful
opportunity to exploit this corona virus
and fundamentally transform America and
I truly think that if we do this right
we have an incredible opportunity
so not just dig out of this crisis but
to fundamentally transform the country
fundamentally transform the country if
that phrase rings a bell to you it's
because that's the phrase that was used
by Barack Obama he said we're about to
fundamentally transform this country
it's part of the reason why we suggested
maybe Obama doesn't love his country so
much is because you don't want to
fundamentally transform things that you
love when I put my head on my pillow at
night lying next to sweet little ELISA I
don't say okay good night good night
honey
I'll see in the morning and you know
then with God just get back to
fundamentally transforming you I love
you so much
I love you so much I want to
fundamentally transform you I want you
to be completely unrecognizable to me by
the time I'm done with you that's how
much I love you
no you don't but the left doesn't love
this country they don't that's why
they're trying to rewrite the whole
history of this country and say that
America was evil and rotten from the
very start and the whole reason that
this country exists was so that a bunch
of evil bigots could defend chattel
slavery and they get fuel at surprises
for writing that in the New York Times
and they get applauded by the left for
saying they're gonna fundamentally
transform America that's what this is
about this is about winning okay and you
can either allow the left to win and say
okay you're right
you got it I'll play by your rules I'll
play my role as the kind of curmudgeonly
conservative who who you know pushes
back a little bit to give legitimacy to
your ideology into your regime but
ultimately I'm going to suspend my
presidential campaign ultimately I'm
gonna pull back I'm gonna let you win
and then the system will move on that's
one type of conservative okay you can be
that kind of conservative if you want or
you can be the kind of conservative that
wins and that's not always gonna be nice
and you're not always going to get
invited to the nicest parties and maybe
your grades are gonna get hurt if you
speak out too much at university and
maybe you're not going to get that
promotion you wanted if you speak up
around the water cooler it's your job
but at least you will be accomplishing
something at least you'll be fighting
for something at least you will believe
in something rather than playing some
clown role some court jester role in in
ideologies that you pretend to despise
but listen you know before we go I saw
this clip on CNN it was Donna lemon one
of my favorite people on CNN there did
too many to count but he's one of them
and Don Lemon has you know let the masks
fall a little bit in recent years he
initially he was a little more of this
serious news man who was objective and
increasingly in recent years he's just
let that fall and he's shown how much he
despises not just conservatives but this
president in particular he wants to
fundamentally transform the country just
like Joe Biden listen to this nasty
monologue he gives about how much he
hates Donald Trump what is it about
President
that really gets under your skin is it
because he's smarter than you better
educated made it on his own
didn't need Daddy's help wife is more
accomplished better-looking I don't know
what is it what is it about him and he's
a black man that's accomplished game
president that he punked you on the
whole birth certificate thing what is it
about him just wondering you think
that's kumbaya you think Don Lemon when
he accuses President Trump of being a
dumb idiot racist who's married to this
awful woman who's also dumb and an idiot
and unaccomplished and you know he
doesn't like his wife and all this do
you think he's just talking about Trump
or do you think he's also talking to
trump supporters seems to me when the
left goes after Trump they're also going
after the Trump supporters Hillary
Clinton made this clear right the Trump
supporters are deplorable and
irredeemable can't be civil with these
kind of people that's what she said
that's not kumbaya that's not okay let's
all just get along I wish we could all
get along I wish we could all be nice I
wish that Donald Trump didn't have to be
mean to Jim Acosta okay I wish that we
could have a more elevated politics of
whittier politics I wish we lived in a
more graceful and elegant time we don't
the left doesn't let us live in that
time because when you push them even
just a little bit that's what you get
that kind of attitude that kind of talk
from Don Lemon
the New York Times rewriting your
history and saying the whole country is
rotten to the core and we got to rip it
all down that's what you get when you
push them those are the stakes so how
you gonna push back you're gonna play
nice and pretend that it's all just fun
and games and it doesn't really matter
if you win or are you going to recognize
that there really are stakes here and
really are things worth defending and we
really do love our country and we really
do love our country min all of our
countrymen even Don Lemon that's why we
want to preserve a good country even for
him even for Hillary Clinton even for
Joe Biden and sometimes you got to be
tough to do it sometimes it's more
important to be successful than to be
liked that's our show I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael an old show
I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austen Stephens assistant director hovel
Woodhouse key editor and associate
producer Danny D'Amico audio mixer Robin
fenders hair and makeup
Nika Geneva production assistant Ryan
love the Michael Knowles show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20 hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host
of the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clifford
[Music]